[Música]
dejamos los temas de la actualidad y
hablamos ahora de actualidad pero
económica hasta con nosotros en el
estudio jorge hurtado jorge muy buenas
noches empezamos hablando de eeuu porque
el banco más grande de este país
norteamericano reportó menos beneficios
de lo esperado hablamos santiago de
hippie y morgan que reportó beneficio
por 16 mil 931 millones de dólares en el
primer semestre de este año eso es un
35,49 por ciento menos en comparación
con el mismo período del año pasado
jimmy morgan justificó su pérdida
señalando que el banco reservó más
dinero para cubrir posibles pérdidas
ante los crecientes riesgos de una
recesión económica fue un mal semestre
también para el banco de inversiones
morgan stanley 9 como 26 por ciento
menos en sus beneficios de la primera
mitad del año en cuanto a los datos del
segundo trimestre en los que más se
fijaban walter esta mañana hippie morgan
registró un descenso de sus ganancias
del 28 por ciento a nivel interanual
hasta los 8 mil 649 millones de dólares
mientras que elevó sus ingresos un 1 por
ciento hasta los 30 mil millones de
dólares estos dos bancos se iniciaron la
temporada de resultados de las grandes
bancas el país las ganancias de
blackrock citigroup bancorp y wells
fargo les seguirán este viernes pasemos
ahora a italia luego de semanas de
varias tensiones en ese país se concretó
lo que estábamos estimando una crisis
política que tiene consecuencias
económicas así es y bueno la manzana de
la discordia está precisamente en un
paquete de ayudas para las familias y
las empresas para que de alguna forma
contenga en la inflación el movimiento 5
estrellas que hace parte de la colisión
de gobernantes no votó en el senado de
emoción de confianza del gobierno del
que forman parte esto hizo que el primer
ministro mario draghi renunciara y que
el presidente rechazara su renuncia la
situación hace tambalear a un gobierno
de unidad nacional que lleva menos de 18
meses en el poder el decreto de ayuda
contra la crisis y la inflación por un
monto de 23 mil millones de euros prevé
estar previa a dar un bono de 200 euros
a trabajadores y pensionados con menos
de 35 mil euros anuales de renta pero el
5 estrellas lo considera insuficiente lo
peligroso ahora santiago es que esto
sucede en medio de los altos precios
energéticos con la alta inflación y
también en plena estrategia para tratar
de diversificar y acabar con la
dependencia del gas ruso italia es lo
suficientemente grande como para hacer
caer el resto de la periferia de la zona
euro su deuda pública es de 252 millones
de dólares es mayor que la de los otros
4 países juntos y demasiado grande
también para poder realizar un rescate y
seguimos en europa porque allí también
están haciendo sumas y restas en cuanto
a lo que resulta el costo de la guerra
en ucrania cuál es el impacto que va a
tener en el 'viejo continente' los
estragos específicamente van respecto a
la recuperación económica de la unión
europea con un menor crecimiento anual y
una inflación récord según las
previsiones de la comisión europea esto
lo dijo paolo quién tolini que en el
comisario de la comisión la inflación de
la eurozona aumentará un 4% en 2023 y
los países tendrán que hacer frente
también a un aumento de los costos en
los préstamos ya que el banco central
europeo va a subir los tipos de interés
la semana que viene por primera vez en
11 año esto decía el comisario
growth forecast binner y nuestra
previsión de crecimiento se ha revisado
significativamente a la baja para 2023
la previsión para este año se mantiene
27 por ciento en la unión europea
es importante entender el porqué de esto
el crecimiento de este año se ve
respaldado por el fuerte impulso del
pasado año y por un primer trimestre
mejor de lo previsto se espera que la
actividad económica en el resto del año
ya no aporte nada a la cifra de
crecimiento anual se podría decir que la
economía europea está pasando de una
fase de ralentización del crecimiento a
otra de frenado el crecimiento del
próximo año se prevé ahora en un 15 por
ciento 0.8 puntos menos que la
predicción anterior y mientras tanto en
américa latina' en argentina que ya
vemos que también vive en turbulencias
políticas en torno a las decisiones
económicas presentaron el dato de
inflación cuánto fue bastante terrible
la cifra bueno de argentina casi llega a
medio año de inflación de lo que había
previsto para todo el año el incremento
de la inflación en junio fue el 64 por
ciento según datos del instituto
nacional de estadísticas y censo pero el
acumulado semestral enero a junio fue
del 36 2% algo por debajo de la
proyección inflacionaria que el gobierno
de alberto fernández había augurado para
todo el año en su acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional ellos se
esperaban entre el 38 y el 48 por ciento
de inflación anual para todo el 2022 la
inflación argentina es casi crónica el
gobierno de mauricio macri le entregó la
presidencia a fernández con un 53 8% de
inflación anual el dato bajó durante la
pandemia el 36% pero en el cierre del
2021 fue del 50% y bueno ahora el dato
que se ubica en 64 los precios no han
tocado techo los analistas proyectan
para este año una subida anual del 76
por ciento que de registrarse volvería a
ser la más alta desde 1991 cuando los
precios al consumidor crecieron hasta el
84 por ciento no está fácil la situación
argentina muchas gracias jorge a
continuación es directo américa el
debate